[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1er janvier 2030 l'homo sapiens sapiens
a évolué l'espèce s'est scindée en deux
branches
l'homo conectus et l'oms solidaris le
premier à des milliers de connaissance
de contacts des gens à travers le monde
à sydney à vancouver à vladivostok
l'autre ne rencontrent presque personne
il vit dans le silence le mot conectus
peut compter sur de nombreux followers
et qu'ils parlent via internet via les
réseaux sociaux
il s'est même acheter des lunettes de
réalité virtuelle avec lesquels ils ne
voient que le monde qui choisit le sien
les magasins qui n'intéresse les
informations qu'il veut suivre ses mails
en temps plus que réelle
l'autre le regard de passer des oeuvres
et il se sait ignorer 2 janvier 2013 un
immense buzz toute la planète
les appareils électroniques ne
fonctionne plus
son césar ce soir numérique l'homo
conectus est désemparé il ne sait plus
comment vivre alors il décide d'enlever
ses lunettes et d'ouvrir les yeux et du
coup il redécouvre son environnement son
quartier ses voisins qui me remarquer
même plus alors qu'il habite là depuis
20 ans et une envie de communiquer en
vérité le saisit le lendemain le bug est
toujours pas réparé alors le mot
conectus s'approche de la personne sdf
qui est toujours en bas de chez lui
qu'il ne voyait plus il s'agenouille lui
parle lui serre la main et ils essayent
de comprendre sa situation au début le
mot solidariste étaient étonnés de ce
comportement totalement inédit mais au
fur et à mesure de la conversation il se
rend compte que si lui avait besoin de
parler
le mot conectus encore plus cette
conversation d'humain à humain et non
plus via des téléphones
des ordinateurs les fait se sentir
vivant un véritable échange vient de
naître
ce scénario n'est pas du futurisme ce
n'est pas de la science fiction
il est en train de naître sous nos yeux
lentement mais sûrement nous le crayon
un peu plus chaque jour
car des obeaux solidaris il y en a déjà
partout autour de nous saurez-vous les
reconnaître votre voisin de palier la
personne âgée à qui plus personne ne
vient rendre visite ou la personne qui
fait la manche au coin de la boulangerie
savez vous qu'ils sont avez vous déjà
entendu leur histoire leur passé leur
présent ou tout simplement leur prénom
avez vous déjà entendu le son de leur
voix ils sont là pourtant en nombre en
france il y a cinq millions de personnes
qui sont en situation objective
d'isolement ils ont besoin de vous de
nous de soutien moral et affectif en les
ignorant
on ignore l'humain notre voisin en fait
on s'ignore soi même cette solitude est
un fardeau énorme pour nous tous hulot
mais d'un animal social ne soit vous
savez on n'existe que dans le regard de
l'autre par l'autre avec l'autre nous
éclaire eric il ya maintenant un peu
plus d'un an aux démarches de la station
de métro rome dans le quartier des
batignolles à paris
après quelques semaines de bonjour et de
sourire un peu maladroit on a entamé une
discussion et ont maintenant on est
devenus amis
on est tous les deux membres de
l'association entourage une association
à but non lucratif dont la mission est
de permettre aux personnes en précarité
de pouvoir compter sur des gens sur vous
sur des voisins est ainsi d'envisager un
avenir meilleur on s'est demandé
pourquoi on avait tant de difficultés
tant de mal à aller vers l'autre à celui
qui est différent celui qui n'évoluent
pas dans nos cercles ou dans nos réseaux
beaucoup de personnes ont l'impression
que les sdf sont différents d'eux qu'ils
vivent dans une autre galaxie dans un
autre univers
mais je peux vous dire moi qui en suis
un con est pas du tout différent de vous
on est volé go mais alors qui ment
qu'est ce qui bloque la peur voilà
l'ennemi de tout temps la peur et tout
ce qu'elle entraîne la gêne dans sur la
culpabilité la crainte du ridicule
le regard des gens les idées fausses il
est préjuge est coriace et en plus de
cette peur viennent s'ajouter les fléau
moderne de l'individualisme de
l'égocentrisme et du temps qui
s'accélère parce qu'en fait même si on
voulait on n'a plus le temps et les
conséquences de sa sont vraiment
dangereuse et c'est en ça que le
phénomène est insidieux en fait on se
croit plus fort que nos liens
comme si on pouvait être fort tout seul
or nous vivons une période de précarité
émotionnel on a tendance à se replier
sur soi-même lorsqu'on vit en couple ou
en famille et d'un autre côté on se sont
surpuissants on a l'impression qu'on
peut se passer de tout le monde mais
souvent ça entraîne des brouilles
amicales familiales et ça peut même
conduire au divorce
on est devenus narcissique c'est un
phénomène malheureusement me présence
sur les réseaux sociaux
et paradoxalement on n'a plus vraiment
confiance en soi ni dans les autres on
est vraiment dépassé par la réalité du
monde autour de nous on le subit souvent
en 2030 on sera à 8,6 milliards d'êtres
humains sur cette planète
réagissons aujourd'hui pour que la terre
ne soit pas peuplé
8,6 milliards d'individus seul dans la
foule le premier victime de cette
société marche ou crève sont bien sûr
les plus fragiles
ils et elles sont les archétypes le plus
représentatif de cette exclusion sociale
ils et elles souffrent d'une pauvreté
matérielle mais aussi peut-être surtout
de pauvreté relationnelle alors
entourage a décidé de prendre le taureau
par les cornes
via une plateforme d'entre aide via des
événements de convivialité réguliers
entre voisins avec elle son domicile
notre association propose de dépasser ce
clivage homo conectus homo solidaris
pour devenir tout simplement des homos
humanisme des humains en fait on veut
juste créer du lien social horizontale
entre les voisins comme vous et les
personnes en précarité dans une relation
d'égal à égal pour agir auprès des plus
démunis il ya quelques grands principes
simples à garder en tête
il faut réapprendre à vivre en société
retrouvez le déclic de faire le premier
pas vers l'autre il faut retrouver la
spontanéité que chacun a au fond de soi
et puis redevenir ses enfants curieux
qui s'émerveillent devant chaque
nouvelle découverte
il faut aussi refuser la fatalité et se
dire qu'on n'est pas impuissant
oublions donc les à quoi ça va servir
pourquoi aider un sdf il ya encore dix
derrière et demain de toute façon ils
seront encore là
non chacun de la valeur par sa simple
présence pour les autres croyez-en
l'effet papillon chaque petit geste
chaque micro action peut initier un élan
global autrement dit par un simple
bonjour un simple sourire
vous pouvez changer le quotidian
quelqu'un un autre conseil ne pas subir
le schéma de pensée unique qui voudrait
dicter nos comportements moi par exemple
j'ai 38 ans donc je suis née avec
internet et voici ce qu'on m'a vendu tu
rencontreras ton amour
kinder tu te déplaces sera seulement
hubert où tu n'oublieras pas de noter
les chauffeurs tuner cuisinera plus le
soir et se fera uniquement livrer des
petits plats et cetera et cetera
en fait on peut aussi décider que non il
n'y a pas de fatalité
on n'est pas obligé de devenir des homos
conectus aveugle à tout ce qui nous
entoure au reste du monde
au contraire pour la technologie c'est
exactement pareil
mettons là au profit de ceux qui en ont
plus besoin
utilisons la à bon escient et c'est pour
ça que avec des gens de la rue où des
gens qui l'ont connu la ruine
l'association entourage a créé un guide
appel est simple comme bonjour
car si nous avons tous envie d'aider
nous sommes encore parfois freiné par
des préjugés des barrières qui nous
empêche de passer concrètement à
l'action
s'il me demande de venir dormir chez moi
qu'est-ce que je vais répondre si je lui
souris
il va penser que j'ai pitié de lui et si
je suis femme est plus qu il va me faire
draguer voilà c'est des questions qu'il
est normal de se poser quel que soit le
côté de la barrière où on se trouve
alors on s'est rendu compte que les gens
avaient besoin d'être rassurés d'être
accompagné ce guidon des conseils
pratiques concrets pour que vous
puissiez aider et je vous mets au défi
de les appliquer ce soir en sortant de
la salle des conseils simples donc à
genouillé vous mettez vous à la hauteur
de la personne pour ne pas lui infliger
de l'aide
vous voyez le du moins dans un premier
temps souriez tendez la main sur bon il
faut être patient parce que cela peut
prendre du temps
alors ne pas imposer son aide paume
mais elle a proposé les besoins de la
personne que vous avez en face de vous
ne sont peut-être pas les ce que vous
croyez
et surtout s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît ne lui fait pas de promesses que
vous tiendrez peut-être pas ne décevez
pas il faut rester dans sa posture de
voisins
nous on n'est pas des super héros on
peut pas régler la situation tout seul
et c'est normal il faut aussi
se garder des préjugés et garder en tête
que toute situation toute histoire est
unique ne faut pas aller à la rencontre
d'une situation mais d'une personne
enfin n'attendez pas de reconnaissance
et c'est sans doute le conseil le plus
difficile à appliquer temps nous sommes
habitués à recevoir des gratifications
immédiates
à chaque bonne action en fait comme dans
toute relation saine
il ne faut pas attendre de retour sur
investissement jetez vous à l'eau
laissez vous guider par votre bonjour
votre sourire franchissait le rubicon
des préjugés et bizarrement ça marche
dans les deux sens
je suis sûr que parmi vous nombreux sont
ceux qui de temps en temps envie de
parler à une personne neutre en dehors
de leur entourage familial amical ou
professionnel
il m'arrive régulièrement quand je bosse
quand je travaille au métro rome paris
on appelle ça bosse et il faut bien
gagner sa vie il ya des personnes qui
viennent me voir qui me raconte des
histoires un jour il ya un jeune
étudiant petit peu timide un peu
introverti il arrive avec une tête mais
je vous dis d'enterrement et il me
raconte en long et en large la peine de
coeur qu'il fait souffrir depuis deux
jours je les écoute attentivement
j'essaye de le consoler du mieux que je
peux et je lui donne quelques conseils
que mon âge canonique peut se permettre
de prodiguer il avait un peu retrouvé le
sourire
il m'a serré la main en me disant merci
docteur
bon j'étais heureux heureux de voir
qu'il avait retrouvé un peu de confiance
en lui et moi j'étais heureux de m'être
senti utile
j'étais tellement heureux que je vais
même pas facturer la consultation
[Applaudissements]
alors tous ces conseils content de vous
donner avec eric
ils sont valables évidemment pour les
plus démunis mais plus largement pour
tous les naufragés de la solitude et
parce qu'il y en a plein les personnes
âgées isolées les personnes lourdement
handicapées les mères-célibataires
marginaliser les personnes réfugiées et
immigrantes en fait tous ces gens pour
point commun de n'avoir personne sur qui
compter
alors redon nous redevenons des homos
humanis recréons cet entourage autour
d'eux montrons leur qu'ils sont debout
qu'ils existent créons tout simplement
un véritable big bang relationnel et
solidaire soyons la preuve que dans ce
monde trop souvent chaotique les humains
les homos humanis peuvent toujours
compter l'un sur l'autre
voilà on voulait raconter une autre
histoire un peu ceux de la sauce c'est à
vous maintenant qu'il appartient décrire
la vôtre et surtout d'aider les plus
démunis
as écrire une nouvelle histoire pour eux
[Applaudissements]